[Música]
maravilha
essa foto aqui é uma foto antiga de um
time de futebol ac de sorocaba mesmo e
esse cara bonitão aqui ele é meu pai
ele gostava bastante de jogar futebol
mas naquela época dele não era muito bem
visto pela sociedade que você vai fazer
quando crescer
como você vai sustentar sua família mas
com o passar dos anos isso foi mudando
eu nasci ele estudou engenharia e quando
eu tinha 7 anos diferente da época dele
ele me colocou numa escolinha de futebol
ele falou que aquilo seria muito
importante para mim que eu poderia
conhecer outras pessoas fazer novas
amizades aprender a perder levantar a
cabeça aprender a lutar bastante para
conquistar os meus objetivos e eu fiz de
tudo isso lá aprendi bastante
além de me divertir é claro e eu me
lembro muito bem quando eu joguei o meu
primeiro campeonato pra mim aquilo foi
mágico porque aquele monte de pessoas do
mesmo time trabalhando em conjunto para
alcançar o mesmo objetivo as dores da
derrota aquela maravilha da sensação da
vitória pra mim pra mim aquilo foi muito
mágico mesmo
e naquele momento eu me lembro que eu
virei pro meu pai e falei pra ele
pai quero ser jogador profissional de
futebol ele olhou pra mim e me abraçou e
falou boa sorte filho bem diferente da
época dele eu continuei tentando
bastante mas vocês me conhecem futebol
então não deu certo
não virei um jogador profissional eu
acho que não era muito bom mas também eu
não tinha muitas pessoas falavam que eu
não tinha a estatura suficiente para ser
um bom zagueiro que era a posição que eu
gostava de jogar nessa mesma época
começou o boom das lan houses
aqui no brasil que eram os lugares onde
você podia pagar para utilizar
computadores para jogar alguns jogos
eletrônicos com outras pessoas da
comunidade
eu já jogava outros
jogos como mario sonic me diverti
bastante mas fui lá na lan house que eu
conheci um jogo muito famoso chamado
counter strike popularmente o cs que
imagino que alguns de vocês aqui já
tenham jogado ou ido na lan house buscar
o seu filho pela orelha porque estava
matando aula e o cs foi algo bem
diferente um jogo muito diferente pra
mim porque eu descobri que também tinham
competições e eu comecei a jogar a
formar minha primeira equipe assim como
no futebol a aprender a me comunicar
melhor com o meu time é saber escolher
quem seriam as pessoas desse time
a aprender com as derrotas levantar
minha cabeça para conquistar minhas
vitórias e foi um momento muito
divertido na minha vida e eu me lembro
muito bem também de quando depois de
muito fracassar a gente conseguiu a
nossa primeira vitória
foi um momento incrível também e alguns
dias depois
eu parei para refletir sobre ele sobre
esse momento e eu me lembrei daquele os
meus colegas que estavam ali
celebrando aquela conquista junto comigo
e eram pessoas que tinham um metro e 50
outras até dois metros umas de 50 quilos
e outras com mais de 100 e aquilo me
marcou bastante porque quando eu me
toquei disso eu entendi que as
competições no mundo dos games eram
diferentes dos esportes tradicionais
porque a maneira como você havia nascido
não interferir na sua performance dentro
do jogo e isso me marcou bastante nessa
época ao tempo foi passando e continua
jogando viagem no brasil jogando com os
campeonatos e e depois de passados
alguns anos a vida adulta bateu na minha
porta
parei de jogar pra entrar na faculdade
pra poder começar a trabalhar e me
desliguei do jogo assim como muitas
pessoas da nossa época eu parei
totalmente jogar
muitos pararam e outros continuaram
jogando e acreditando que aquilo poderia
dar em alguma coisa esse cara aqui onde
é o gabriel ele jogava junto comigo a
gente era do mesmo time e ele falou pra
mim que ia continuar jogando
ele até desistiu da faculdade dele na
primeira semana quando perguntaram o que
queria ser andamento da aula de
engenharia ele falou que queria ser
jogador profissional de jogo que nem
existia se isso na época ele levantou e
saiu da faculdade eu falei pra ele
algumas vezes que eu achava que aquilo
não era uma boa ideia para a vida dele
mas mesmo assim ele continua
alguns anos se passaram e em 2015 ele me
mandou uma mensagem ele falou que estava
indo jogar um campeonato na frança
eu achei aquilo muito estranho porque
fazia quase sete anos que eu tinha me
desligado desse mundo e foi cara isso
ainda existe o que está acontecendo e
ele me explicou um pouco eu fui
pesquisar e eu descobri que tinha um
dado um nome pra isso que a gente vivia
lá atrás que hoje se chama de esportes
vende electronic sports esportes
eletrônicos
então você pode estar se perguntando a
mas então se o jogo mario sonic quem de
creche eu sou um atleta não é bem assim
né
dentro dos esportes existe um
ecossistema profissional muito sério
para fazer com que tudo isso existem que
ele possa ter ido jogar na frança e por
exemplo ele é um jogador profissional
ele estava jogando profissionalmente
nessa época ele existem os times que
pagam salários para esses jogadores
porque existem fãs que assistem os jogos
desses times que compram merchandising
desses times que vão aos eventos existem
patrocinadores que apóiam esses
campeonatos essas equipes porque tem
muita gente assistindo e uma das coisas
que me recordo também aí que me marcou
bastante é desse cenário profissional
desse ecossistema
graças a todas essas pessoas que
assistem muita coisa é possível hoje em
dia
então por exemplo no brasil este ano na
verdade aqui em sorocaba
existe um campeonato de counter strike
que teve 300 mil espectadores ea equipe
isso é equivalente a praticamente três
estádios do maracanã lotados
o ano passado teve um campeonato de liga
por legends que é um outro jogo que
passaram mais de 96 milhões de pessoas
assistindo à transmissão e esse ano no
outro jogo do campeonato de dota
tivemos uma premiação de aproximadamente
140 milhões de reais distribuídos pelos
jogadores
isso mostra que o mercado existe e está
crescendo cada vez mais e aí você pode
se perguntar mas pessoas assistindo
outras pessoas jogando videogame
porque é que isso acontece e isso é mais
normal do que você pensa hoje em dia até
por esses números
isso acontece também cada vez mais e
você pode estar se perguntando e você
pode estar se perguntando você nunca se
perguntou na verdade porque tinha às
vezes você assistir um jogo de futebol
porque existem 22 pessoas correndo atrás
da bola é uma questão de costume mesmo
da própria sociedade que está se
transformando a cada dia
então nos esportes hoje existem pessoas
que assistem os torneios
simplesmente porque elas querem se
divertir ou então porque elas querem ver
habilidades extraordinárias de outros
jogadores já que daquele jogo que ela
gosta ou também para expressar aquele
senso de competitividade que a gente
tinha quando criança porque imagino que
a maioria de vocês já tenha praticado
algum esporte ou participado de alguma
competição quando criança e conforme o
nosso tempo vai passando a gente vai
crescendo e tendo menos tempo para esse
tipo de coisa e muitas vezes a gente
expressa essa nossa competitividade
através da torcida de outros jogos
torcer para um time ou idolatria de
grandes atletas
então muitas vezes é até escuta alguns
amigos falando quando assistir um jogo
de futebol do time que ele torce a nosso
ganhamos ontem sendo que ele nem estava
jogando né
então isso acontece muito nos esportes
tradicionais assim como também acontecem
nos esportes eletrônicos
uma das outras coisas que permitem que
tudo isso seja possível é além de
milhões de pessoas assistindo são as
milhares de pessoas que trabalham nesse
mercado
então você pode fazer diversas coisas do
mercado de esportes muito mais do que
você imagina então tem alguém que
trabalha na área de comunicação
marketing alguma coisa então no mercado
de esporte também é possível você
trabalhar você pode ser social media de
um time de um jogador
você pode criar conteúdos em vídeo para
essas equipes
você pode trabalhar na área de marketing
divulgando algum produto criando algum
produto vendendo merchandising daquela
equipe tem alguém que trabalha ou estuda
direito alguma coisa assim e no mercado
de esportes você também pode trabalhar
existem advogados que são os advogados
dos jogadores em negociações de
contratos com seus clubes de contratos
com direito de transmissão imagens dos
clubes com grupos de transmissão
quem aqui trabalha o estudo na área de
administração
assim como em qualquer empresa no
mercado de esportes também existem
diversas empresas onde você pode
trabalhar na área de rh financeiro
contabilidade e é tudo isso que faz com
que o esporte cresça cada vez mais todas
essas pessoas assistindo tantos fãs se
engajado e muitas pessoas acreditando
nesse sonho e trabalhando nessas
empresas ou criando as suas próprias né
e aí vocês se lembram do de um espólio
que eu passei slide
vocês se lembram do gabriel que mostrei
a uma foto lá atrás que ele continuou
jogando e hoje esse cara aqui dentro do
nosso mundo dos esportes
ele é conhecido como fã ele foi duas
vezes campeão mundial de karatê strike o
time dele se já ganhou mais de 3 milhões
de dólares em premiação ele foi eleito a
maior personalidade diz parte do mundo o
ano passado e hoje ele é meu sócio nos
nossos projetos
aumentar o esporte aqui no brasil e na
américa latina a e isso mostra o quanto
o esporte está crescendo no mundo
essa aqui é uma foto que me lembra um
dos momentos que eu quis me tornar um
jogador profissional de futebol
além daquela sensação da competição que
eu tive eu me lembro da primeira vez que
eu fui num estádio lotado eu sentir toda
aquela energia e eu falei que eu queria
falar que estava tudo pronto pra eu
estar naquele lugar
essa outra foto é uma foto de um
campeonato de cautela extra já que
aconteceu no brasil este ano
o ginásio do ibirapuera estava lotado e
toda vez que eu olho para essa foto
eu fico pensando que daqui a alguns anos
o meu filho vai poder olhar pra mim
falar pai eu quero ser um profissional
de esportes e eu vou poder dizer pra ele
boa sorte filha
obrigado